que lazard ki zerbo philosophe et
chercheur burkinabé en sciences humaines
bonsoir lazare ki zerbo merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france en 2015
il ya eu l'élection de roch marc
christian kaboré et depuis 2015 le
djihadisme et et les attaques n'ont
cessé de se multiplier
quel est l'enjeu aujourd'hui ou plutôt
pour demain pour cette élection
présidentielle et écouter le burkina
faso et d'une culture démocratique
enraciné et donc l'élection est une
dimension de la vie démocratique en 2014
2015 il ya eu ce chamboulement liée à la
chute du régime de blaise comparé à vail
suite à une inspection et je pense que
déjà le taux de participation sera une
bonne éducation d'une éducation à la
fois parce que il ya ce problème de la
tactique violents dans plusieurs régions
du pays mais aussi pour montrer si c'est
sursaut démocratique qui a marqué
l'insurrection est toujours vivace et si
notamment la jeunesse adhèrent à ce mode
de transformation politique par les
directions et donc c'est le taux de
participation sachant qu'il y a des
parties du territoire où les élections
ne vont pas pouvoir se tenir
tout à fait mais je pense que c'est un
facteur limitant
on ne peut pas considérer que cela omez
remettre fondamentalement en cause ce
street
je pense que les indications que l'on
amd que vraiment ce participations sera
c'est normal mais il faudra en tenir
compte je pense que au delà de cet
élément n'a de cet indicateur la classe
politique
aujourd'hui a besoin de renouvellement
toutes les personnalités que vous avez
présentées sont évidemment une dent dans
majorité président sortant des autres
dans l'opposition mais elles
appartiennent quand même à la même
génération
je pense qu'elle aime bloc qui est
arrivé à l'occasion de la révolution de
1983 d'impression cette génération là il
ya une cassure en cours de route
notamment à partir de 2012 et avec les
sélections mais il faudrait qu émerge
dans tout cas une nouvelle classe
politique parce que pour un
renouvellement il ne s'est pas seulement
les idées aux portières renouvellement
il faut voilà d'autres la jeunesse
d'avoir aurait pu avoir été aussi
imprégné de toutes les valeurs qui ont
été défendues par les mouvements
populaires démocratique au burkina parce
que c'est un pays encore une fois où la
culture des montagnes était vraiment à
racine et et cela même en dehors des
périodes électorales
et c'est surtout ça le baromètre le vrai
baromètre de la vie politique au burkina
faso c'est que pensent les syndicats que
pensent les étudiants que pensent les
paysans parce que dit le manifeste et
donc il faut que tu déprendre de tous
ces éléments là et je ne suis pas sur
eux
la classe politique qui participent à
cette présidentielle
vous pourrez à refléter cette vitalité
et cette vivacité de la culture de nos
particules c'est le peuple effectivement
qui avait chassé blaise compaore du
pouvoir en 2014 aujourd'hui l'opposition
souhaitent son retour
comment l'expliquer
mais écouter l'opposition sait qui c'est
bien parti le cdp qui est parti d'une
baisse comparé et cela aussi se drape
dans l'est les oripeaux de la la
réconciliation donc il dit
réconciliation du retour du chef de
l'état mais je pense que ça c'est un
défi pour l'avenir parce que l'ancien
président ne peut pas revenir sans
condition
il ya eu quand même la réflexion d'une
insurrection de 2014 2 fin 2014 il y à
la mort de thomas sankara dans le procès
avance pas mal les avancées
significatives cette année donc je pense
que ça ce sont des éléments en tout cas
de l'équation réconciliation à quel prix
la réconciliation va falloir franche et
parce que d'autres composantes de la
société qui ont vu les martyrs tombés
notamment 2015 en septembre 2015 dans ce
qu il ya d une tentative de l'ancien
régime de revenir qui ont vu des
personnalités comme norbert zongo
assassiné ce qui a donné un collectif
populaire crête listant donc je pense
que ça il va falloir que le peuple de
trois ans avec les nouvelles autorités
et les ce retour n'est pas quelque chose
qui peut se faire de façon aussi simple
je pense que dans tout pays démocratique
les institutions sont ceux qui comptent
nous avons aujourd'hui un haut
commissariat dans une institution pour
la réconciliation et l'unité la
réconciliation
il y à un conseil constitutionnel il
faudra donc
7 ces institutions là reflète la
maturation progressive de la vie
politique au burkina faso la situation
sécuritaire si vous ne voulez bien au
burkina faso depuis 2000 15600 burkinabé
sont morts dont 400 militaires un
million de déplacés et quand je parle de
sécurité la sécurité alimentaire aussi
est un des enjeux
qu'en est il du bilan justement de roch
marc christian kaboré va-t-il pâtir de
cette politique sécuritaire qui ne porte
pas vraiment ses fruits ou pas selon
vous écoutez le sahel tempier 1 du
nigeria au mali est fragilisé et that
accepts par ce délitement aussi de
l'état parce que nous armés n'était pas
préparé à ce défi qui est lié à un hymne
à ce qu'on peut dire asymétrique où
l'ennemi fait à côté de vous et être
habillé en jean baskets et un tee shirt
dont c'est un défi que et d'art mais
aussi puissante que celle des etats-unis
ou d'autres n'ont pas réussi à avec je
pense que c'est vrai que l'on reproche
dans les opinions publiques
or servent cesser le massacre
dans le nord il y à la région de divo
valeur à fada il ya eu vraiment des
épisodes extrêmement sanglant
extrêmement meurtriers mais je crois que
fondamentalement la société pour qu'il
avait vis encore sur le régime de ses
valeurs de tolérance d'acceptation c'est
un pays très courriel il ya soixante
ethnies avec une culture politique et
sociale de d'intégration de cohésion
avec ces mécanismes extraordinaires
telles que la parenté à plaisanterie
donc je pense que quelle que soit
l'issue du scrutin
ces fondamentaux là vont rester et la
menace aussi sera s'est progressivement
qu'elle sera résorbée donc je ne pense
pas que vient-elle pas justement du du
manque de la présence de l'état dans le
pays
oui mais nos états sont des états
d'aller dire fragile faible et ce n'est
pas en cinq ans à mon avis que le sap et
ses raisons mais il faut que le
collectivement
moi je crois beaucoup à l'intégration
africaine à la cedeao
il n'est pas normal à mon avis que des
forces étrangères telles que les profs
en thèse vous reviennent américain donc
non africaine vient de régler ce
problème il faut que nos stratèges
analyse la nature de la menace
c'est une menace asymétrique prennent en
compte des facteurs tels que l'équité
territoriale
il faut que les régions telles que le
nord du mali le nord du burkina faso de
l'est du burkina le soir intégré dans
l'aménagement du territoire national et
ça ce sont des choses qui vont se faire
progressivement
donc je pense que on ne peut pas
considérer que nos états sont en fait il
ya des écrits sont de natures diverses
au mali peut-être que le mal
extrêmement avancé prononcer mais je
pense que le burkina tassera encore des
ressources et des ressorts pour réduire
cette menace at il effectivement un très
meurtrière depuis deux ans merci
beaucoup lazare ki zerbo d'avoir répondu
ce soir à nos questions sur rt france